j'accueille aujourd'hui ça déjà le bois
les plus connus au québec par madame
pousse-pousse bonjour à déambuler et
bienvenue à radio canada international
bonjour c'est mieux merci pour
l'habitation alors vous allez on vous
connaît au québec à travers le couscous
cosmos un couscous 'conserver' berbère
qui nous vient du maroc et il ya
quelques temps vous avez embarqué dans
une nouvelle aventure qui a abouti au
lancement aujourd'hui d'une gamme de
produits la chef
parlez nous de ce concept ben pour vous
parler de la chef il va falloir pourra
peut-être tout l'historique de cosmos
comment ça s'est passé pour comprendre
un peu de congé
déjà il faut savoir que moi j'ai
travaillé longtemps dans le
communautaire et particulièrement dans
les tables de concertation
j'ai un esprit une façon de voir le
monde qui est un peu différente de des
affaires dix ans alors je suis plus dans
l'entré dont on travaille ensemble
je ne suis pas dans la compétition du
tout du tout du tout et pour moi il faut
mobiliser les gens c'est quelque chose
que j'ai développé savez que c'est une
très bonne mobilisatrice aller et je
parlerai j'ai juste une parenthèse quand
j'étais dans le communautaire j'avais
suivi une formation avec centraide
aujourd'hui donnée par dynamic dynamo
pardon est scellé de chip rassembleur
alors c'est comment rassembler avoir de
lee jinman et de chypre qui rassemble
les gens c'est pas c'est le bon
leadership la cité en avons été pas ne
s'agit pas toi qui ont maman tu as même
des gens sa sage léger jeu les applis
j'ai épousé cette façon de voir le monde
et un jour j'ai lancé cosmos alors
cosmos au début c'était vraiment pour
partager partager un peu ma culture et
ma culture berbère ses dires le signe de
la culture berbère
c'est vraiment le manque d'ardeur
commence là où commence le couscous au
maghreb voilà alors c'est lié à notre
identité pour moi ca lien c'est un lien
avec ce que je suis avec mes racines
alors j'ai commencé par le cos cause
mais j'avais plein d'idées mais ça
tournait toujours autour du maroc
la gastro mais aussi de la culture les
arts
j'avais plein d'autres projets et ça a
été dur ça a été beaucoup plus dur que
ce que je pensais
je savais que ça allait durer mal sauté
des disciplines entrepreneuriat compter
pacte n'a pas grandi là dedans c'est
normal que ça soit difficile mais ça a
été beaucoup plus dur que ce que je
pensais de tout ce qui ne devrait pas
nous aurons fort comme en voilà et 10
ans et sacré été ma force tout moment
c'est que malgré le fait que chaque fois
que je tombe et je me mettais de pas le
jour en 2018
et c'est là je vais aller vers la chef
la maintenant en 2018 il y avait le
lancement de couscous dans tous les
géants surveille spi ya eu une embûche
je n'en pouvais plus j'ai dit ça y est
c'est fini je faire alors j'ai appelé
j'ai appelé mon contact
geagea au bureau chaque puis j'ai dit
regardez j'en peux plus désolé je vais
me retirer
j'arrête et il avait déjà fait la
commande était vanté ce que vous avez
acheté puis c'est fini
et là elle me dit qu'est ce que tu vas
faire et là je dis pas regarde moi au
début ce que je voulais c'est une
plateforme où je vais aller chercher des
femmes de toutes les cultures pique je
lui pas puis là je lui explique ma mon
concept et là elle me dit ah non j'ai
levé le projet dans les délais mais a
marqué sur un nouveau projet mais voilà
alors que vous avez est ce que vous avez
laissé tomber le
non mes produits non ah bah c'est ça
alors on est en 2018 l'automne 2018 on
s'est dit on va sauver alors une bureau
chef allait m'aider pour régler mes
problèmes que je rencontrais tout le
temps que c'était toujours la même
histoire celle usine c'est la production
c'est ça qui a toujours été un problème
on va t'aider à régler ça on va
travailler ensemble pour faire rentrer
des nouveaux produits dont lui ferais ça
va te permettre c'est d'augmenter de
grandir un tout petit peu et après on va
lancer le nouveau preuve le nouveau
projet là on parlait encore de cuisine
du monde c'est comme ça que la cliente
ans pour commencer
et là on rentre ça a pris un tout 2019
alors on rentre le corps gelé partout on
revient on trouve une usine unique aussi
on fait rentrer deux congelés partout et
on rentre le 11 février
non mais en janvier le l'automne 2010 9
g une rencontre avec tous les bureaux
giflé le directeur général de de sobeys
québec sera et là on s'est dit non ça on
le veuille ou valait vraiment très loin
avec ce produit est vraiment le concept
est intéressant
alors là j'en viens sediba regardé comme
le couscous frais va rentrer pour ne pas
créer de la concurrence
on va arrêter le couscous congelés et on
va lancer le couscous frais le 11
février 2020 et au mois de juin 2020 on
va rentrer cuisine du monde encore on
l'appelle encore président du mans alors
là où travaillent 11 février le frère
entre le 15 mars le 13 mars tout ça le
confinement et lakovic c'est que moi
j'avais arrêté le couscous congelés on
l'avait arrêté en janvier on a pris une
grande commande qu'on a dit c'est fini
et il commande qu'ils allaient nous a
menés jusqu'à juin et pour le vrai c'est
sous la marque c'est près de gea et il a
il arrive en bac pro bac est alors il
n'est pas portionné et larivot vrac
risque à l'intérieur c'est dans les
magasins qu'on va le port
mais là ils ont fermé ces départs avec
le confinement ça fait que le le 14 quoi
avril 2020 j'avais plus rien sur le
marché j'en avais plus rien qu'on veut
rebondir opposants ne rebondit hebinger
j'ai appelé mes bailleurs de fonds on a
arrêté les paiements de factures alors
qu'ils travaillaient aussi j'étais
obligé de revenir travailler j'arrive
silence et achat solidaire mais avec
achat solidaire c'était du bénévolat
c'était juste pour sourire les
entreprises et là on reporte le
lancement de cuisine du monde parce que
tout le monde essayait numéro chef
essaie d'aider les magasins en 71 ans
nadeem en la reportant septembre l'été
on se rend compte que ce n'était pas
possible et on l'a reportée jusqu'à
janvier pig la save et le langer
aujourd'hui et se croit le sait quoi le
consoler vient enfin le concept lui-même
c'est alors ça c'est difficile
la fz1 très motivant par longtemps joué
voire discret c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui me tenait son innocence mais
ça a été comme j'ai dit ça a été très
difficile et est depuis mon passage au
dragon il ya plusieurs femmes qui me
contactent ideom aussi de toutes les
cultures des québécois de partout
partout qui me disent comment t'as fait
comment t'as fait pas je dis je suis en
train de créer marque et je fais pas
d'argent j'ai pas de salaire encore mais
je leur explique quand même ce que j'ai
fait alors je donnais de bénévolat jaune
et du temps je donnais vraiment je donne
beaucoup d'heures ou à toute personne
qui me copains et en faisant ça et je
commençais à coacher du monde
bénévolement tout le temps mais là je me
rends compte qu'il y a qu on a tout la
même problématique beaucoup d'immigrants
qui veulent faire découvrir leur culture
qui vont vers la cuisine parce que parce
que c'est quelque chose qui nous permet
de rester lié à ce que nous sommes
tout en s'ouvrant à notre nouvel an
menton à porte puis ça fait plaisir de
faire découvrir ce que tu es un autre ça
fait vraiment flipper mais on a tous le
même problème alors je me suis dit si on
applique les terres chypre a semblé si
on applique cette notion de travailler
ensemble alors j'ai commencé à en parler
à des filles à des entrepreneurs
c'était naturel pour moi d'aller vers
des femmes réfléchis tu es mon parcours
du engagement mon cv tu as et c'est tout
à fait normal pour moi d'aller vers la
alors j'ai commencé à parler avec des
femmes qui n ont pas l embarqué en
barque qui l'a l'idée c'est que chacune
de sa culture une femme par pays
chacune partagent avec nous une recette
une des exigences que j'avais c'est que
la recette doit être au lien avec elle
vraiment son histoire c'est une recette
de maman de grand maman c'est important
que ce soit une recette qu'on aime c'est
comme pour moi le couscous
qu'est-ce que ça devrait être vous avez
rassemblé combien une dizaine de faim
c'est la hot line est ce qu'il ya des
gens qui viennent de liron du cameroun
du japon du maroc alors et vous vous
avez choisi c'est qu'un produit que vous
avez choisis pour vous à moi c'est
habillée c'est d'elle que je sus pâte
six débatteurs aux france n'appelle pas
de club comme les appelle en france
c'est plus une pâte que un couscous et
le nom original le nom vraiment selon
désir initial qu'on retrouve pas là
encore seul marché et la recette si la
recette initiale du pin cng xiiie siècle
vous êtes remonté jusque là où il
cherchait les violets parce que ces
saveurs la trouvent preneur ici au
québec on est à vue car d'autres goûts
est-ce que vous adapter et demi je sais
pas ce que vous rajoutez quelques on va
essayer le plus possible de garder mes
recettes originales
bien sûr il ya une industrialisation on
va pas se mentir non c'est mais on a
vraiment essayé de garder la recette
originale on a été pour le japon par
exemple on a été chez
chez le meilleur je me rappelle pas de
sens non excusez-moi mais on a été
chercher un seau ya particuliers
japonais pour faire la recette japonaise
pour on a fait la même chose pour tous
les produits dites moi vous vous êtes
vous êtes une berbères du maroc vous
êtes habitué à ce que nous tous sont
préparés à la maison
comment vous acceptez que ce soit dans
surgelés dans un frigo comme ça or
comment vous est passé de piques à une
autre adaptation c'est l'adaptation de
façon générale mon jeu qu'à quelque
chose que je dire régulièrement on est
commune comme un art nous les immigrés
on a les racines qui doivent absolument
qu'il doit garder
puis on a les branches qui doivent
s'adapter alors le cosmos c'est ma
racine j'y tiens on le mange
régulièrement chez nous mais il faut
l'adapter
il faut l'adapter ici au québec et à la
nouvelle vie maintenant bien sûr j'ai
été sévère à ce niveau par exemple et
c'est quelque chose qui me coûte très
très cher colonisés je refuse que la
semoule soit cuit elle comprend gic la
semoule qu'on ajoute de l'eau bouillon
jeu ça fixe à dire énormément mon ma
marge passe ça coûte cher mais
aujourd'hui 10 est obligatoire de les
faire cuire à la vapeur et 3 voix alors
ce fut une des exils c j'essaye de
trouver un juste milieu entre un
couscous fait maison et un couscous
industrialisés et ça c'est le plus grand
détail la deuxième chose je refuse qu'on
achète simplement parce qu'un autre
c'est le mélange où le débit moi
j'aimais 17 hippies ce que j'ai écrit et
on prend chaque épice tout seul c'est le
mélange effet à luzy alors ça me permet
de garder quand même en quelque sorte la
qualité du produit
je comprends est-ce qu'on peut
l'imaginer qui ok là vous avez vos
produits je parle un peu à radiall h f
dites-moi est-ce qu'on peut imaginer une
adaptation québécoise du couscous je
sais pas je vais dire une hérésie par
exemple
on lui rajoute un peu la poutine je sais
pas ce qu ce terroir
le couscous terroir c'est quoi c'est
c'est le costaud ce qu'on fait au maroc
avec les oignons confits le miel voyez
surtout dans la région de fès qui puisse
une recette juive je crois plus que
bernard est bien celui là bas je
l'échangé gg utilise le maïs au lieu du
blé et le maïs et les berda qu'ils font
pour baisse pour une cause comme
maîtresse alors on utilise le maïs on
utilise les cours
la canneberge et s'est inspiré des trois
soeurs chez les amérindiens qui ont des
fèves qui ont le maïs et ce quoi la
troisième chose la courge
donc c'est à espérer que sahil bûcher
travail ça puis j'ai développé aussi une
boutique peut-être que ça va être
commercialisé je sais pas mais il ya une
poutine à la maison c'est vous voyez
c'est je travaillais avec la recette de
poulet au citron confit et les all i
love
ok là je les retravailler la poste on
est en plein ramadan et qui est connu
des mois khadija avec toutes les
difficultés que vous avez réussi vous
avez le sourire et vous avez de
l'émotion en lançant ce produit
aujourd'hui
dites moi qu'est ce qui fait courir à
des jeunes - ah qu'est ce qui la laisse
fonctionner il la laisse il la laisse
pas lâcher en fait il ya plusieurs
raisons premièrement c'est une promesse
coussement c'est une promesse à mon père
avant son décès j'ai dit à mon père que
je fais le faire je vais aller jusqu'au
bout et je crois que quand tu as une
motivation comme celle là y'a rien mais
rien ne peut empêcher c'est d'arrêter
deuxième chose c'est celui-ci a défini
je suis malade de travail je me retrouve
d'entrée
ac c'est là je travaille beaucoup j'aime
ça travailler et j'aime les défis et
hitch pas quelqu'un qui aime rohff faire
la même chose je suis pas une suiveuse
je vais l'emmener faire quelque chose
que quelqu'un fait conclure vous
toujours créé il faut toujours arriver
avec quelque chose de bien
donc est ce que j'aime vraiment dans la
chef cycle sobeys s'est engagé à
soutenir ces femmes alors les familles
nous donne des recettes et en
contrepartie ils surviennent des
redevances mais le plus important pour
ces femmes c'est tout
toute la visibilité que son pays gère ce
québec et jr va nous donner et va donner
à ces femmes et chacune des femmes
en fait les femmes sont toutes des
entrepreneurs elles sont toutes dans
l'alimentaire il ya juste une qu'il
n'est pas dans l'alimentaire mais et les
les accompagnatrices des femmes qui se
lancent en affaires en alimentation
alors il accordé en est rien oui
puissant père un chef
alors il a grandi là dedans c'est marie
de l'italie mais toutes ces familles
sont des entrepreneurs puissent obèses
et commençant leur donner plus de
visibilité qui va pouvoir utiliser comme
levier pour faire propulser leur propre
entreprise
et c'est ça que j'aime dans ce projet
c'est ensemble si je vais pas avancer
tout seul
j'aurais pu faire ce projet tout c'est
mais c'est pas ça ils se sont habitués à
rassembler wemhoff la question dernière
question
j'aurais aimé avoir plus de temps m je
suivrai savoir vous en tant que femme
d'immigrants ont donc enfin les
immigrantes
est-ce que vos défis sont un peu
particulier c'est que sont vos gars oui
oui oui et c'est ce qui me fait que
c'est ce qui fait que le travail que
j'ai choisis devront lakovic c'était
justement avec un organisme
communautaire et pour soutenir
l'entrepreneuriat des femmes immigrantes
c'est ce qui fait que je donne
l'information lancement d'entreprise
juste pour les femmes pour des crocs
deux femmes immigrantes surface glisse
la communauté culturelle parce que c'est
elle qui ont le plus de défis et c'est
ce qui fait aussi que je suis bénévole
avec femme et sort pour travailler sur
comment faire mais ça pourrait aider les
femmes de communautés culturelles
alors oui on a des défis particuliers
que ce soit des difficultés de nous de
notre façon de voir le monde de notre
façon de faire les affaires qui sont
totalement différentes de nos propres
blessures si vous voulez qui perdure
depuis des siècles il ya ça qui il y à
aussi là comment on nous voit tout
commence comme une image de on dirige
tout en restant diplomatique only way il
ne va pas bien travailler où il papa
sans qu'un jour il va lâcher les liens
communs combien préjugés soumis un
préjugé qui est là qui rend la tâche
extrêmement difficile qui il y a aussi
le fait que garder pour immigrer là on
arrive aux moyens quand unique anémique
en in économique normale a comme moi
comme je croisais merlin faut avoir un
diplôme universitaire faut avoir deux
ans d'expérience falloir encore le plein
de bonus alors y ait plusieurs ça fait
qu'on arrive à mettre six ans et
comptent en effet 26 30 ans mme allan
horloge biologique d'autre ça sonne et
là tu as envie d'avoir ton bébé pilar
ici le bébé qui arrive qu'il faut
s'installer faut travailler il faut les
sortants sont maintenant bien souvent
faire tous en même temps il faut
s'intégrer il faut comprendre qui fait
tout ça en même temps
alors ça ce match tu peux vraiment
commencé à faire une entreprise tu as
déjà dépassé 36 ans et ben là c'est
l'âge qui arrive la fatigue tout sa
piscine les enfants bien sûr qui
continue qui il ya aussi toutes les
subventions dont tap les droits oui non
au passage qu'en rachetant au mais c'est
a plus droit aux subventions c'est juste
des prêts des prêts des prêts à des taux
à n'en plus finir
alors c'est vraiment tout ça les
licences
c'est beaucoup de choses sont
particulières aux femmes bah écoutez
rajabaly je vous souhaite bonne chance
pour votre nouvelle aventure et je vous
remercie beaucoup d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de radio canada
merci samu